oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] put this on my computer day I mean
I avoiding coca bloos
I love that [ __ ] for later damn oh damn
yeah keep telling me about that
patchnotes baby tell me about that
gladiator buff oh yeah that was the
single most disgusting thing I have ever
recorded in my entire life but yeah
welcome to the face reveal boys yeah
it's not really much either or I'm
either gonna get two types of comments
the damn you didn't look how you
expected Wow no [ __ ] or the damn this
dude's hot as [ __ ] let me get this guy's
number of pipe is ass and I mean I'm
okay with that it's completely fine nuns
do it for the boys you know no homo it's
completely fine fun fact I don't like
this but my camera actually makes me my
skin look paler than I actually am it's
pretty [ __ ] disgusting I don't like
it but either way boys thank you guys
for 10k and if I believe if I check the
channel right now we're at like ten
thousand five hundred and it they
literally just took like a day and a
half and we already gained five hundred
selves it's absolutely incredible so
thank you guys so much for that I didn't
feel like boring you with my either
really attractive or really disgusting
face depending on the type of person you
are
so I put a gameplay on the background it
should be either Dominion gameplay or
one of the trials because I'm trying to
get that steal either way it works just
out completely fine and don't worry
about 90 percent of the video you're
gonna be seeing me looking at my
computer this one behind me for no
[ __ ] reason basically anywhere that
isn't right at your face because I'm not
used to this I usually read stuff off on
the notepad which is right here next to
me so I usually don't do that much you
know looking at cameras and whatnot so
if you see me looking around it's a
force of habit I pauses I'm gonna try to
stop that for this video but to start
off the Q&A we're gonna start with the
huge question probably the most
requested question what is my age and no
it's not thirty it's not 22 its 17 as
weird as that sounds I'm still in high
school
I haven't even graduated yet I'm
graduating in two months though what I
haven't graduated yet a lot of people I
assumed I was older enough it's because
the voice or whatever but that's just
how it's gonna be
next up woven says are you a tit man or
an ass man and that's just a fair fact
like ask man 100% and
here's an in-depth analysis of wine
shown in the hallway but you may be
you're still in high school or me if
you're walking on the street doesn't
matter
you're gonna but you're gonna be walking
down to this fat-ass bro this big
thottie bro walking down the hall or
walking down the hallway walking down
the street doesn't matter you look at
her ass bro she's in front of you you're
behind her she ain't gonna look around
and if she does look behind you you just
looked over that way completely safe
looking into girls boobs bro you're
staring basically right at her eyes just
a little bit lower and then she's gonna
do that [ __ ]
eyes up here then you're caught they
didn't look like a [ __ ] idiot but
then you might be asking yourself just
wear sunglasses and my answer to that is
no who the [ __ ] were sunglasses in the
hallway next question of us from Dez he
says who was your favorite character in
the for honor beta or when you played
for honor for the first time and my
favorite character at the time was Ken
say I've played ken say you know the
season 1 Ken's day was absolute garbage
like I I didn't like Ken's a season one
or season two but I still played him
because I thought he was cool but then I
realized that he took a lot of work he
definitely took a lot of skills so I
definitely you know big collapse to
anybody that still plays Ken saying you
know before the rework and all that but
I eventually dropped him to play with
gladiator so I was very happy when
gladiator released next up is from rhyme
and he says what is nugget porn okay so
we so basically nugget porn is normal
porn except either both adult actresses
or actors or whatever happened whatever
combination happens to be at least one
or more of them maybe all of them
basically don't have any arms or any
legs and they're just a body with like
stubs and a head it's pretty [ __ ]
weird and I love how Bronco over here
says don't look it up I just made that
mistake what did you expect the the word
porn was in the question and what were
you expecting like unicorns and some
rainbows or some [ __ ] next up is
Christopher and he says at gingy do you
have a girlfriend yes but she doesn't
need to know about that
for all you know I could be single right
now men hit me up no ladies only men
fragile ass does the carpet match the
drapes yes if Kay men has a four it has
four questions so I'm gonna just roll
through these things real quick favorite
graphic novel you could say your
favorite one overall or you can list
like the top three I don't really read
novels or books that much and I actually
did Google book graphic
I'm an absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
really I didn't really you know read too
many graphic novels I did read a few of
the Batman type one so that I would say
that's my favorite I'm not really into
graphic novels as much where or when
were you born
I was born in 2000 so I gonna get then
he asked what's your favorite food pizza
definitely when you put pineapples on it
belt like mmhmm yeah and then four do
you think a four on a graphic novel
would be a good idea to make asking for
a friend clearly he's not asking for a
friend he's asking for himself but I
think a 400 F and that would be really
nice I know we need like a more
narrative type because we only have the
story for four on her and there really
isn't much to that but it there is a
decent amount and it is pretty fun to
play I love the campaign of this game
but definitely a graphic not be a really
nice idea to make right he asks a
question for the Q&A who was it that
inspired you or motivated you to do
YouTube and actually got the motivation
to do this from a youtuber who used to
play call of duty and he still does but
he plays a lot of fort and I recently
that's Jeff I don't know if you guys
have ever heard of him he is one of the
phase members growing up when I was like
you know in middle school I was like
holy [ __ ] phase is [ __ ] awesome like
every type of Call of Duty kid at the
time but I like Jeff a lot because he
always stuck with the content obviously
the other phase members have done like
vlogs and [ __ ] and some other stuff but
Jeff always stuck the content and I
definitely enjoy that and just his
attitude and it was really fun to enjoy
his videos so I definitely say Jeff
inspired me the most to do YouTube dark
Saint asks what are you gonna do after
for honor dies down are you planning on
covering other games he's just sorry if
that if that sounded rude I didn't mean
it like that bro no shame so good didn't
sound rude at all obviously games are
gonna have to come to a close at one
point in foreigners going to be on that
list of course I mean I wish 400 didn't
ever come to a close and it just kept
updating but obviously we can't always
have that I am currently doing monster
honor wolf content and I've been having
a blast a monster hunter so I'm
definitely gonna keep uncovering that
game there's a few games in the future
that it might look promising like anthem
and skull and bones but I know I'm not
really big on pirate games the only Park
game that I do have is see if thieves
and that one I prefer more than skull of
bones just at this moment and I might
cover anthem in the future I'm still
kind of figuring it out it's been
getting like mixed reviews because if
it's because EA is the main company
that's making it so I might do anthem it
looks like a fun game but if it is I'll
do it if it's not then we'll just figure
it out from there
max R says question how did you start
your channel is it a slow process and
how do you get subs I've started a
channel on my own
account I need some advice Congrats on
the 10k by the way thanks for that max
but basically I started my channel like
two years ago and I was like I once
again I got motivated by other people to
do it that seems like the whole wave of
what happens youtubers post videos the
their subscribers watch their videos
it's like damn I wish I could do that
too and then they end up kind of being
like that not like a carbon copy of them
but like being inspired to do videos cuz
of that just like how I was with Jeff a
couple questions ago and right he asked
me stuff like that and to answer the
next part of the question it is a slow
process it's it takes a lot of grinding
especially basically think of you
starting out with zero literally nothing
on YouTube if you have any friends or
family that would be fine to subdue you
and watch her videos definitely stick to
that I got I started my channel with
zero subs and I ended up having friends
that discover my channel cuz I told them
about it and I ended up getting to like
eleven then I ended up making some
titanfall 2 videos didn't really get
much traction maybe got about 80 90 subs
before then and that for honor comes out
and then I'm just starting to like catch
this whole group of people all these
subscribers it was this constant info
and it was a lot of fun it is a slow
process you kind of just have to pick
the game and kind of be very original
with it it is very key to be original on
YouTube and that's how you I feel you
would get sub to the most like picture
the scenario let's say in for honor in
this instance let's say every single
youtuber that you've watched on form or
spliced have a goal BEF be brave in a
mean everybody that you've watched on
for honor
including me of course all did news
content we all did the same [ __ ] that I
do on my channel but everybody else does
it too it gets repetitive and it's like
well if I watched it for the first
person why would I watch it for the next
person there's no point because right
under the info there's literally no
reason to watch the video twice that's
why people like to be original with
their stuff that's why it most people
have moved to gameplay or edited
montages like Jerome me with news stuff
like that so you definitely want to try
to find a lane that's original next up
is from cryo and he says when your
channel gets bigger will you troll will
you still try to respond and interactive
viewers and that is a 100% yes it will
get hectic and streams the more people
that said to my channel because
obviously that means the more influx of
people go into my streams but as you
know because you've obviously been in my
streams
anybody else that's been on my streams I
will even go back in the chat even if I
miss something from the beginning I'll
always go back and check because I hate
especially being in big channels like
one huge twitch streams like if you ever
watch like a fortnight's stream most of
the popular that people have like 30,000
to 40,000 people in their stream and
it's so difficult to get a question just
instead of the only way to basically do
it is if you donate and I don't want you
people guys I don't want you guys
donating to me just for a question I
think that's redundant leo says holding
cross or daubeny see that's kind of a
hard one
cuz Dobbin he's a [ __ ] but he's also
really cool I kind of like him holding
cross is kind of a badass but I kind of
like Bob anymore but like I said Dom
he's a [ __ ] so like you know up holding
girls will go with him on that one dude
you're the sexiest man alive but I don't
know what the butt is you better start
telling me that [ __ ]
what's your fit he says what's your
favorite game of all time and why and
it's either gotta be the Lego Star Wars
series like the Complete Saga like
that's some heat right there or spyro on
the ps2 wait and by the way remastered
Spyro your boy almost nutted from that I
swear to God I saw that news I had like
an instant boner from it but those are
more the old games in terms of new games
I would probably say the Metro series
Metro 2033 Metro what is it like last
light and then they're coming out with
Redux soon and I'm absolutely excited
for I've been a big fan of the Metro
series love the concept
so yeah it'd be Lego Star Wars Spyro or
Metro blue says what care do you think
is the most broken beserker with his
400m esse lights or shaman next question
is from Dorsey King and he says Q a were
you from and then country I am from the
United States of America the good old
place the Purvis Dobbin es what's your
secret to getting all this [ __ ] I don't
get [ __ ] I sit in my room and play for
honor a lot and then the occasional
other game I don't get [ __ ] so I don't
know what you mean by that next question
is from limitations XD uh-huh rawr XD
baby he says what made you decide to
play for honor and basically I've been a
big fan of medieval games I loved Skyrim
to death that's also one of my favorite
game of all time but I had to put Metro
inspire and all that [ __ ] first but I've
I love Skyrim the most like I still play
to this day I still continuously turn up
the game and mod it cuz mods come almost
every day with fresh content so it's a
lot of fun to play and it's just like
this never endless fun what I enjoyed
about scaring the most was the medieval
stuff with the swords and the bows and I
just I'm a very big fan of that I watch
a lot of movies like that I watched
Monty Python the Holy Grail a Highlander
all those old type of medieval movies I
loved them gladiator 300 all that stuff
big fan of them then when I saw the
trailer for four and I was like holy
[ __ ] this is like the dream come true we
got samurai we have Vikings and we have
Knights and they're all fighting each
other like there's no way that this is
like this game is bad it was absolutely
amazing when I played the beta and then
I just stuck with it from there next
question is from viperous tuna and he
says how many foreign are youtubers do
you know and play with now there's a lot
of foreigner youtubers on xbox I have
played with Angelus 2700 I randomly
queued up with him in a game and then we
happen to disconnect as foreigners trash
I played with Supreme Cato in the same
way I basically played Dominion we
connected together he knew who I was I
know who he he was so quite a few games
with him and I've also played and talked
with
efb before if you actually check one of
his videos I believe it's the spawn kill
times 3 video one of his most recent
ones I think it like 9:20 or something
like that you can actually see a
gladiator get his ass clap by two people
that's me
we're up till 5:00 in the morning
recording that video and we weren't even
really recording he was just getting the
gameplay for it me and Kato were just
having fun with it with some other
person as well but other than that in
terms of people that aren't from Xbox I
mean I've collab what spliced before so
obviously I know him I know flu curse
influx the block's Hound of Tara J
karela Jerome Kenzo nice arc wizard CJ
Tony all those types of people and gold
the Ameena on PC raving gaming there's a
lot of foreigner youtubers that I know
and I've watched a lot of their videos
and I can't forget about my [ __ ] boy
Talon was so baby didn't forget about
you thought about you thought I did but
I didn't saving you for last
next up is from mr. sááá and he says for
the Q&A what is your ethnicity and can
you speak another language I cannot I
took Spanish in high school and I ended
up dropping it because of how hard it
was for me to even understand a second
language and my ethnicity probably say
black or you know african-american next
question is from a cell layer the
sunlight warrior love the name by the
way shout out Dark Souls also for the
Q&A do you
job or you could paid for this and if
you do what's your profession and say my
name please
solar the sunlight warrior there I said
your name I said it twice
there you go but I do not have a job I'm
still currently in school trying to get
that done but I do get paid for YouTube
as I'm assuming most other cons Ingrid
especially in the foreigner community do
get paid for this
so yeah I'm mostly focusing on school
and then just doing YouTube as like a
hobby I am still getting paid for it
it's obviously nothing to live on my own
for but like it doesn't really matter at
this point since I don't need to depend
on YouTube for my income the insane God
says dude are you gay
maybe but [ __ ] 1 3 4 ocher says what's
your dick sites for the QA of course for
absolute research purposes only
I understand bro dick size kind of like
all right so like take a football field
right like from end zone to end zone
do you own one of those blades of grass
on the field it's about like 1/8 of that
next up is Matthew Moyer and he says
hashtag Q&A
why the name gingy and before anybody
asks it is gingy ok not Ginji not Genji
none of that [ __ ]
ok it's just gingy so you take the
beverage gin and then combine it with G
as in gee what an [ __ ]
gingy that's how you say it so I don't
want any more fuck-ups again but I chose
the name because I had this I've always
had this nickname of why people call me
ginger cuz obviously my red hair and
then other stuff like that and then I
was like how can i shorten this even
more then I had a friend to me
consistently call me gingy's like yo
wassup gingy I was like what's up man I
was like damn that's a perfect name so
that's how I stuck with it fun fact if
you actually go on my early for honor
videos and all of my titanfall videos
you actually see a different name and a
different intro I actually had an intro
that somebody made for me and my name at
the time was gaming ginger it was
absolutely the most cringe East thing I
could have ever come up with but I
didn't know what to do and actually on
my thankee 100 subs video I actually
changed I even said in the video that I
was changing my name so you could check
that out and cringe with me because it's
absolutely disgusting and I so stupid
for even making that exquisite clip says
can you answer my question of why my dad
left me no because I'm still trying to
figure out why for me psychotic ninja
says this for the Q&A what are good tips
on gladiator I just started playing him
a lot of people ask me this and I don't
know why I'm really not that good as
even though I'm rep 29
utilize the zone it's the safest and
most disgusting zone attack I've ever
seen in the game besides peacekeeper and
if you [ __ ] it up you can faint it so
there's that on top of that definitely
you know utilize his skewer and his tow
staff for opening up opponents and other
stuff like that
use the buckler punch as well to open up
opponents and then it just are fainting
your heavies into lights from different
directions kind of do some stupid [ __ ]
Gore leg up and down and lift right
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] cuz it works every
time and then obviously throwing the toe
step just absolutely piss them off and
then zone attack them and then it's GG
Kalp whitey says why did you choose
gladiators remain crazy look cool
Oh G Mello says how far do you think
this game has come in terms of when it
was released and honestly I think this
game has come a very long way and season
one we didn't have any dedicated servers
had no heroes had a lot of basic [ __ ]
there wasn't really much season 5 we
have a training mode for new players the
new parry changes with the heavy into
light and light heavy all that weird
[ __ ] we have new heroes we have the
dedicated servers we've come a very long
way in this game I just wish that
majority of this was added in the
beginning that so that no the connection
issue was solved and most the players
didn't leave right away but we're slowly
getting them back our kuda says have you
ever have you played any real fighting
games like Mortal Kombat and Tekken and
if yes which fighting game franchise do
you enjoy slash enjoyed the most
I have played Mortal Kombat injustice a
bit of Tekken and then a lot of Street
Fighter and out of all of them I have to
say Street Fighter was my favorite not
because there's a lot of women with huge
butts we're gonna ignorant that's a
bonus but I definitely enjoy Street
Fighter there's the ultra combo moves
that you can do and it's just the car
I'm big on cartoonish games like that's
why I've liked for a night more than pub
G and stuff like that because then you
could really [ __ ] around with it you
don't have to be you don't have to be
taken seriously for it and I just
enjoyed Street Fighter else cuz I was
better at it than Mortal Kombat occupies
442 says would you [ __ ] me I'm a
pufferfish by the way yeah [ __ ] it under
anything once and then to end we have
cow gar and he says why you bully me
yeah you
while you bully me but anyway guys it's
going to be the end of the video today
hope you guys did enjoy the face reveal
the Q&A you probably hate my face you
probably don't hate my face doesn't
really matter I'm probably not gonna be
doing the face cam too often and if it
is maybe on a special occasion I'm
probably not gonna be using it like I
said as much probably during streams and
definitely not during videos other to
keep the audio and the voice only that's
just how I like to do it I want people
to focus on the audio and the gameplay
other than having to look at my face
that's another thing they have to pay
attention to that's why I don't really
do that but either way boys like the
video if you did enjoy it really does
help me out subscribe if you're new if
you somehow came to this video I cover
Monster Hunter world content like
soullow guides and tips and all that
other good stuff as well as for honor
videos with informational side that
being data patch notes leaks info
updates all that stuff that's like the
cover on both those two games so that
sounds interesting definitely stay sub
to the channel obviously with
notifications on because YouTube is
[ __ ] you boy over of course with
people not getting notifications or
whatever dumb [ __ ] they haven't to do
this time my two most recent video is
gonna be on screen if you guys want to
check that out highly recommend you do
with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day thank you all for 10k or
10.5 K or whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it at this point some Layton
take a lot of time to do these videos
but thank you all for 10k guys are
absolutely amazing we're killing it what
subs thank you guys for all that I'll
see you guys later peace out